i am really excited to be back with the
chessup board for more content what
you're about to watch is a game i played
in slovan aronian uh in which we play a
game on this board i played the stafford
gambit against lavon we played using an
assistance mode now i was uh i was
getting assistance meaning that when i
touch a piece i could see what's a
blunder and what's the best move in this
case d6 would be the best move it's lit
up green but i played knight c6
and we play the game from one of my
favorite dubious openings and i really
hope that you'll enjoy the content and
if you're interested in getting a
chessup board link will be in the
description they are still available for
pre-order and a small disclaimer is a
board does not come with love on
erroneon i don't think he's in stock
right now but uh you can use coupon code
rosen to save on this links will be in
the description and i hope you enjoy the
video let's go okay good luck goodbye
all right
so three two
it's time
for the staffer gambit
okay
can you sell this somewhere
have you studied this no no
look sorry
okay
[Music]
okay what can we do let's just play this
solid
solid
save
uh-huh sorry if i play bishop okay so
now i can
okay this is still my preparation
it is it is look at you
[Music]
don't need the assistance just yet
okay this next to be eliminated okay
yes yes this i like
now he wants to play some queen d6 stuff
and capture the poem
so we need to play queen d2
[Music]
okay let's do this anyway
there we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm not that easy
who is that guy stafford
that's the very first game in the
database he played this opening
one in like six moves or eight moves
got the name
oh wow
[Music]
i don't think that makes me happy don't
think i handled it well
[Music]
oh
two green options
multiple good moves i want to take the
pawn but
i also just want to force repetition
wait this move looks more fun
we were about to find out dammit
[Music]
i messed up
sorry
oh
[Music]
now i need to
go for a draw
okay
[Music]
so many greens
is everything to draw yes thanks oh no
ah it's gonna be a draw
i kind of plundered
[Music]
yeah the queen c3 i don't know 22 was
bad i should have played queen e2 we
need to uh
coin this g3 because i forgot that 22
and this is just three quenches three
right there's some end games which white
is better but throw drum how do we how
do we accept the draw
should we just i think if we repeat
it'll recognize it's three-fold yes yeah
that's it
[Music]
okay i got a little bit of help from the
board but okay one more okay
you want to crack the stafford